[Musik]
dieser krieg wird natürlich vor allem
mit waffen ausgetretene sind waffen die
menschen töten waffen an denen man
stirbt trotzdem wäre die vorstellung die
waffen sind das eine und alles andere
sind neben sachen etwas naiv sowie eine
finanz sanktionen unter umständen
größeren schaden anrichten kann als ein
kampfflugzeug so geht es halt auch um
den kampf der bilder nicht zuletzt in
einer weltöffentlichkeit
die dann eben eine rolle spielt in
diesen in der frage wer ist der
schuldige wie reagiert die ganze welt
öffentlichkeit und diesen wettstreite
bilder denn hat wolodimir zielinski aber
sowas von gewonnen und putin hat ihn so
krachend verloren
und beides ist interessant zu betrachten
bei puten es interessant zu betrachten
dass er jahrelang
verstand sich selber als
gegenmodell als verkörperung des anti
westens hinzustellen als der wille
starke
kampfbereite entschlossenen mann der
sozusagen den ganzen westen dekadent
dastehen dass der sozusagen gehen dem
verdacht in den westen gegen sich selber
dekadent zu sein oft perfekt aufs
perfektesten bedient hat
damit ist jetzt einfach schluss das muss
man einfach sagen nur hypothetisch
was putin jetzt der welt für bilder
geschickt hat osten kreml er selber
keinen
star
umgeben von höflingen
das war aber alles andere als eine
vitalität wie realitäts und
männlichkeits inszenierung es war das
pure gegenteil also fast schon fast
schon geisterstunde im kreml also wenn
er nicht so böse werk könnte einem fast
leid tun und dem steht eben entgegen
wolodimir vilimsky von dem man einfach
mal sagen muss er hat sie auch gelernt
ein
[Musik]
gelernter schauspieler
was aber
seine verdienste nicht schmälert weil
auf der einen seite natürlich er weiß
wann man
grenzt wann man lächelt wenn man ernst
kommt mit welcher körpersprache man
seine botschaften verbreitet er hat auch
einen sinn dafür was ein guter spruch
ist und was eine pforte ist und warum
man seine
überzeugungen oder seine appelle
sozusagen in gut geformten portiert und
setzten in die welt hinaus
sprechen muss
ändert nur alles nichts daran dass man
diese sätze beim nennwert nehmen kann
und dass hinter einer inszenierung da
das absolut echte erst seelands gesteht
geben in den straßen von kiew
das ist echt die russen sind hinter ihm
her das ist auch echte gefahr in der er
schwebte die
lebensgefahr oder zumindest die gefahr
gefangen genommen zu werden
sie ist real und unter diesen
bedingungen sein können auszuspielen die
richtigen inszenierungen hinzulegen
verfälscht nicht etwa seine botschaft
sondern unterstreicht
welche regionen präsent
er ist so wie auch amerikanische
politiker gelernt haben vielleicht nicht
im schauspiel unterricht aber sozusagen
ihr charisma anständig auszuspielen und
so wie es eben leider
unsere deutschen politiker nicht zurecht
könne
man muss also selensky für beides
bewundert für sein können
was inszenierungen angibt und für seinen
mut diese inszenierung in unter großer
gefahr durch zu ziehen
und
jetzt
bin ich hier wie skurrile objekte
brüssel rosig wie 413 ist hier
barcelona andres gerber sowohl mit dem
rio ob es ihm natürlich etwas hilft ich
hoffe es hilft ihm etwas ich hoffe der
umstand dass er so viele leute
überzeugen konnte mit diesen auftritten
hilft ihm und seinem land
ehre der ukraine will er gesagt hat vor
dem europäischen parlament
[Musik]